500 feet to snapchatting climbers have
reached a new milestone in their latest
attempt to summit Mount Everest together
Adrian Ballinger and Cory Richards
posted this new video earlier today when
they made it to their tent
they've been documenting every step of
their journey on snapchat this is the
second time the duo is trying to climb
without supplemental oxygen last year
only Korey made it to the summit Adrian
had to turn around when he was just over
1200 feet away the two are now within
3,500 vertical feet of the summit Dana
Jacobson is following their expedition
Dana good morning good morning Cory and
Adrian set off for Everest a month ago
with two goals in mind the first to make
sure Adrian reaches the summit this year
and the second to capture that moment on
snapchat 25,000 feet got done what we
need to do Mount Everest looms overhead
as Adrian Ballinger and Cory Richards
current altitude known as the Death Zone
where oxygen levels are so low human
survival is nearly impossible it's hard
I mean the body's not meant to be here
they reach the North call on Thursday
with the Eddie Bauer Everest team for
most climbers this rugged mountain pass
is the closest they'll get to the summit
our bodies don't love us right now yeah
I'm feeling pretty wasted but Cory and
Adrian plan on ascending and
snapchatting right to the top without
supplemental oxygen a breathing hard
just sitting training for summit day is
rigorous custom diets give them a
metabolic kick to combat altitude
sickness so I'm eating a lot of sugars
which is what helps my body operate up
here their heart rates and oxygen levels
are meticulously monitored as they move
higher up he's actually doing really
well
that's a good it's a Herculean effort to
survive one of the world's most
inhospitable regions it's estimated that
nearly 300 people have died attempting
to scale Everest last month swiss
climber Ueli Steck fell to his death in
the same area Cory and Adrian had been
training his legacy is huge and it
always will be and I'm not sure it will
those are she
that can be filled the pair braved a
violent storm in sub-zero temperatures
last year while acclimating to low
oxygen tents collapsing on itself
unfortunately aap had to turn around a
little bit earlier so it's up to me to
hold it down
that's the summit only kori made it to
the top with just over 1200 feet to go
Adrienne's dream was cut short it's
nothing really felt right I wasn't
hydrating that well I wasn't eating that
well and I definitely was really cold I
knew I was already getting to that point
where I wouldn't be able to get myself
down alone the pair expects to summit
Everest together and undertaking they
hope to share with thousands from the
top of the world the reminder to to
really make sure that it's still worth
it that our values are in the right
place that we're doing this for the
right reasons and we're willing to
accept that risk
now last year Cory spent just three
minutes at the top of Everest but his
cellphone battery died if you remember
before he could snapchat the moment this
time they plan on bringing extra power
so their snapchat followers will not be
let down and there's good news nine
Sherpas made it to the top they summited
yesterday so they could lay down those
rope lines and that begins the quest for
hundreds of climbers this year to summit
oh wow they were both so determined
because they came here as you know
before they went they looked really
great and healthy at that point yeah
they did we hope they make it for this
reason - he declined to go thinking it
might be a problem not only for his life
but also affecting is partner exactly we
want to see him do it this time because
he made it obviously it I mean he
summited six times with oxygen you want
to see him achieve this place Thank You
Dana
always good to see you